you know it's I hate giving advice that  I don't know like self-awareness I don't  want to teach you self-awareness like I  don't I don't know how I got gratitude  it just happened like maybe I'm in to my  feelings I don't think I figured that  out it wasn't like those little nine  step process to get to my feelings I'm  just into my feelings and so I cuz I'm  into my feelings I know how thankful I  am I know how lucky I am  guys I used some of you've heard me say  this before you know where it is to  become a human like what do I mean I  mean the math around actually becoming a  human being is [ __ ] insane like  you've won you get it you get it and so  like I thought about [ __ ] like that I  think about [ __ ] like what if my family  died like I think about what I actually  care about and it makes me happy